I know you guys are used to my crazy
phone videos but this is actually a
serious video
it's something I'm pretty passionate
about so I hope you'll take the time to
listen
would you drink this right now 1.1
billion people don't have access to
clean safe drinking water that's one in
six of us unsafe drinking water and lack
of sanitation is the cause of 80% of all
sickness and disease and kills more
people every year in violence yeah
if you check within the community I
think about 6 the passion of the
community as sick as suffering from the
same problem waterborne diseases On
February 12 2009 over 185 cities around
the world are organizing a charity event
through Twitter it's called a twistable
you get it
Twitter Plus festival we're bringing
together communities to raise money for
charity water and a hundred percent of
the money is going to the cause did you
know that $20 can give a person 20 years
of clean fresh drinking water in Africa
how because charity water doesn't just
give water they give access to water
drilling a wall can cost anywhere from
four to twelve thousand
that's why we need your help I'm helping
to organize the LA trust of all but
don't worry there's festivals all around
the world
so check testicle comm to see if there's
one in your city lastly check the link
in the sidebar for a link to my blog
where you can donate if you're not able
to make it out to at Westerville
remember a hundred percent of the money
is going to charity and don't forget we
don't have to drink this we're lucky
enough to have this but not everyone is
one last thing I'm also making a
collaboration video for the trustable so
if you'd like to be a part of that just
record yourself holding up a dirty glass
of water if you can get this in to me
before Friday that'd be amazing if you'd
like to have a little speaking part you
can say right now 1.1 billion people on
the planet don't have access to safe
clean drinking water that's one in six
and you can also hold this up and say
would you drink this what if this is all
you had again and be so appreciative if
you guys could do this it'd mean a lot
I'll post the final video here and I
look forward to getting your submissions
any other information need to know is in
the sidebar or on my blog and I just
seem calm so thank you guys very much
you